premier mort dû coronavirus au soudan du
sud il s'agit d'une personnalité de haut
rang dans ce pays d'afrique de l'est et
compte désormais 2 131 cas un mois et
demi après l'apparition du premier
malade une propagation qui inquiète les
organisations humanitaires dans les
camps de déplacés
surpeuplées et la medjahed pas facile de
respecter la distanciation sociale et
les mesures d'hygiène en particulier
dans ce camp de déplacés internes à
jouba ou trente mille personnes
s'entassent la croix rouge sur place
lance un cri d'alerté
nous sommes particulièrement préoccupés
par le fait qu'il y ait eu quelques cas
qui ont été testés positifs dans le camp
ici juste à l'extérieur de juba il y a
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays qui
vivent là donc elles sont très à
l'étroit et je pense que la grande
difficulté que si vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui vivent dans une seule maison
peut-être sans eau courante à
l'intérieur il est très difficile pour
les gens de respecter le lavage des
mains
la distanciation social le port du
masque tout ce genre de choses dans ce
camp deux cas de kovy 19 ont été
détectés selon les autorités
sud-soudanaises certains vivent depuis
plus de 50 ans cette structure gérée par
les nations unies dans des conditions
très précaires
il est nécessaire de distribuer des
savons à la fois du savon liquide et du
savon dure aux communautés qui en ont
besoin pour que nous puissions continuer
à appliquer les mesures de protection
être le co vie de 19
c'est l'un des défis les plus importants
par exemple dans nos chambres vous
trouvez dix personnes dans la même pièce
vous trouvez trois personnes sous la
même moustiquaires à partir de là
comment peut-on appliquer la règle qui
dit de mettre une distance une distance
entre chaque déplacer compliqué à faire
appliquer dans tous les camps du soudan
du sud un autre cas de couronnes un
virus a été signalée dans un camps
similaires abritant près de cent vingt
mille personnes à benq dans nord du pays
le soudan du sud qui a lancé ce jeudi en
collaboration avec le programme des
nations unies pour le développement
un centre d'appels gratuits d'urgence
sanitaire pour lutter contre la pandémie
mais malgré l'augmentation du nombre de
cas juba a décidé la semaine dernière
d'alléger certaines restrictions en
autorisant notamment la réouverture des
marchés des magasins des bars et des
restaurants
la crise sanitaire actuelle s'ajoute à
une situation politique et sécuritaire
est déjà difficile au soudan du sud
les habitants se remettent à peine de la
guerre civile qui a fait en six ans plus
de 380 mille morts et un million et demi
de déplacés internes